you can't play me [__]
I'm the [__] that plays
[__] [__]
[Music]
cut
all right everybody let's get reset we
are going again
Nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah Tom well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an American tough wow I'm
just so glad that we got you out of that
BBC commitment so you can play with us
Cheers Cheers Antoine listen I'm just
now buying that you're someone that was
born and raised in the streets of
Brooklyn
that's weird cause I actually was born
and raised on the streets of Brooklyn
I was in the gang and everything most of
this stuff actually happened to me wow
okay well that's that's great for us
because I want you to use it okay it's
good first take let's just uh let's get
going let's go let's get going